I'm really excited to kick off this
semester
and I'd like to thank the organizers
again for putting this all together I
think it should be a really great
several months here really productive
and enjoyable so I'm going to introduce
interactive truce
and I'll start just with an outline of
how the next two hours will go for those
who are not familiar with interactive
truce some of the technical terms in
this outline won't make sense but I did
want to give just a sense of what you're
going to see rather than just diving
into it so obviously start with the
definition and motivation for
interactive proofs and interactive
proofs divides derive their power from
the combination of randomness and
interaction so what I'll actually start
by talking about is not interactive ruse
I'll just give a couple of stark
demonstrations of the power of
randomness on its own and this section
of the talk will also introduce some of
the technical ideas that will be useful
when we actually see a very efficient
and powerful interactive proofs then
I'll introduce some important technical
concepts for the design of efficient
interactive proofs
namely notions called low degree
extensions in arithmetician and then
we'll see what's really the key hammer
like the one hammer you really need to
know to design efficient interactive
proofs which is called the Sun check
protocol and then we'll apply the Sun
check protocol to a certain problem
called sharp set and then we'll see a
notion called doubly efficient
interactive proofs which is actually the
notion that's most relevant to this
program so just so you know roughly what
the topics will be even if they don't
all make sense at this point all right
so when you think about interactive
proofs I think it's helpful to have the
following scenario in mind it's just one
application scenario but it makes things
very concrete so imagine there is a
computationally weak user maybe it's you
with your laptop who is using a
commercial cloud computing service to
store in process its data okay so you
send a bunch of data up to the cloud who
stores the data and you might also store
the data or maybe just some kind of
summary of the data and then later you
ask the crowd
the cloud a question about your data
which might be of the form you know hey
cloud please run this analysis on my
data and the cloud responds with the
answer but you don't trust the cloud so
you would really like a guarantee that
the answer is correct you're not just
going to blindly trust the cloud so you
start interrogating the cloud sending a
sequence of challenges and receiving a
sequence of responses and at the end of
this interaction with the cloud you have
to decide whether to accept the answer
as valid or reject it as invalid now in
general these challenges will be
randomized that ensures that the cloud
cannot predict in advance what the next
challenge will be so a little more
formally in any interactive proof there
are two parties approver which
throughout this talk I'll denote with
the red P and a verifier which will be
noted with a blue V so in the previous
scenario the cloud is acting like the
prover and you are acting like the
verifier or your laptop is so in an
interactive proof to prove ourselves a
problem and tells the verifier the
answer and then they have a conversation
during which the prover tries to
convince the verifier that the answer is
correct any interactive proof has to
satisfy two requirements so the first is
called completeness which roughly says
that an honest prove er who follows the
protocol perfectly will convince the
verifier to accept the answer as valid
so sometimes we require this to hold
just with very high probability but
every interactive proof you'll see today
this will actually hold it always so an
honest prove it will always with
probability one convince the verify so
soundness the other property roughly
says that if the prover lies and returns
an invalid answer then the verifier will
reject with high probability okay so
this has to hold even if the prover is
computationally unbounded and trying to
trick the verifier into accepting the
incorrect answer even though it's not
correct this is the definition of
interactive ruse
there any questions about this this is
the most important slide of the next two
hours okay so if the prover returns an
incorrect answer we refer to like the
the maximum probability with which the
prover can convince the verifier to
accept as the soundness error of the
protocol so we want the sound of Sara to
be as low as possible very close to zero
ideally okay so let's forget about
interactive proofs for a little bit and
outside yeah so the way this was
originally formalized I think people
will often just say any constant
probability even like a third but that's
not useful in practice when you're using
these in cryptographic applications so
just think probability to the minus 120
something like that cryptographic lilo
and all of the protocols we'll see today
you can always drive the soundness error
as low as you want
possibly with just some additional you
can drive it to formerly negligible in
the input size if you want yes so you
can't you can formulate negligible
status error the same way cryptographers
do that technicality that won't be
important for understanding the talk
so you can always repeat any protocol
like logarithmic Li many times in the
security parameter and it's the number
of times you repeat it this sound this
hair is going to fall exponentially
quickly with that this so it'll depend
on how much security one in your
application I mean typically with and
then so people often draw a distinction
between okay let me take a step back
real quickly so that tomorrow you're
gonna hear about argument systems which
are the same thing except soundness is
only required to hold against
computationally bounded provers and
people draw a distinction between like
computational error and statistical
error this is all statistical so I know
if you would like the the chance that
the prover convinces the verifier to
accept an incorrect answer you know with
probability 2 to the minus 80 we can
achieve that and that means like in the
entire age of the universe even if you
let the prover try over and over again
he's not going to succeed and you're
probably not going to let the prover try
more than once
so in general we're just for this talk
or just we're gonna want this to be low
and it's going to be easy to make it as
low as we want okay
so let's forget about interactive proofs
for a little bit and just talk about the
power of randomness so I want to start
with a very stark demonstration of the
power of randomness in the context of a
problem called the communication
complexity of equality so in this
problem there are two parties Alice and
Bob and let's imagine Alice and Bob is
geographically separated maybe they live
across the country from each other and
Alice has an n-bit string that will call
a and Bob has an ended string that will
call B and their goal is just to
determine do they have the same string
and they want to determine this while
exchanging as few bits as possible so
all we care about is the number of bits
they send back and forth to each other
that's the communication complexity of
equality now there's a trivial solution
to this problem which is Alice can just
send her whole bit string the Bob and
Bob can just check does Alice's bit
string that she just sent me equal my
bit string and output yes if so and no
if not now what is the cost of the
solution well it's it's n bits because
alice is sending all in it 4 bits to Bob
that's not very interesting but it turns
out for deterministic protocols this is
the best you can do so we're thinking
interesting is if you allow the protocol
to be randomized and have some small
probability very small of outputting the
wrong answer so here's a randomized
solution so first a little bit of
notation alright so I'm gonna let F
actually throughout this talk be a
finite field of size at least about N
squared if you've never seen what a
field is before it's just a set equipped
with addition multiplication division
and subtraction operations and if you're
familiar with the integers modulo P for
a prime P that's always a finite field
so you can think of F as just all of the
integers modulo some prime P as long as
P is bigger than about n squared and
what Alice and Bob are going to do is
they're going to interpret their bits as
elements of the field so you know 0 is
an element of any field and 1 is an
element of any field so they're
interpreting their bits
field elements and then Alice is going
to interpret her input as just the
coefficients of a polynomial which I'm
gonna call P so P is a polynomial over
this field and Bob interprets his input
as a polynomial Q over the field and all
they do is the following Alice picks a
random field elements and sends the
field elements and the evaluation of P
at that input to Bob and Bob just checks
does his polynomial agree with Alice's
polynomial at that one point so he's
convinced that they're actually equal
inputs and if not he says no that these
are these are not equal there's no proof
we've forgotten about interactive proofs
for the next like five minutes
no just Alice and Bob who want to know
are there two vectors equal okay that's
the whole protocol does it make sense so
Alice and Bob are just interpreting
their inputs as the coefficients of two
polynomials and seeing do the two
polynomials agree at a random input no
no no interactive proofs every it's just
Alice and Bob talking to each other and
they're they're cooperating to figure
out other inputs the same so this is
just an example of sort of power of
randomness yes yes and the techniques
were using here with polynomials will be
later these technique is optimal it is
yes it will be optimal to get to failure
probability that they're going to
achieve what this is will you be
factoring the computation cost as well
no so for this so this is
computationally very light but as far as
communication complexity goes we only
care about the bits exchanged but yeah
Alice and Bob and this protocol are
running in time linear in the size of
their inputs because I mean evaluating
this polynomial at a random input is
time
so they can't really do better than that
since they have to read their inputs
even if we did care so so x2 I is so so
this is just a definition of the
polynomial X is an indeterminate here
where the input they evaluate to
probably Nomos at is R which is a field
element that Alice chooses at random and
Bob knows what R is because alice is
going to tell him when R is this well go
see Logan this correct and that's the
next bullet point so I've given up
theory maybe I'm taking too much room in
Cuba given there's only like N squared
or so values are this oh I guess by the
time you trying to integrate you might
as well right yeah let's uh I'll analyze
the cost of this protocol shortly so
maybe ask your I guess my question is
sitting you drive it down to zero
the bigger the field is the lower the
chance they output the wrong answer in
this protocol so and this is what kind
of what I was saying before is if we
want to drive the failure probability as
close to zero as we want we just going
to have to work over bigger fields
okay so this is the protocol and
actually the analysis of the protocol
has kind of come up in questions now but
let me go through it real quickly so
firstly what is the cost of this how
many bits does Alice and the Bob or she
only sends to field elements to Bob R
and P of R and that the field has size N
squared so specifying each one of these
field elements is about two log n bits
so the total communication cost is just
order log n does that make sense it
takes to write down two elements
I want to give this value P of R that
Alice sends to Bob a name because it's
going to come up several times
throughout this talk so I'm going to
call it the reed-solomon fingerprint of
the vector a at R this is referring to a
notion from coding theory P of R is
actually the evaluation of something
called the reed-solomon code it's a
random entry of that encoding of alice's
vector a but that's really just to give
some name to the value P of R okay so
let's talk about the correctness of this
protocol that is what is the probability
that Alice and Bob output the wrong
answer so the correctness of this
protocol is captured in two claims the
first is if Alice's input actually
equals Bob's input so they're two
vectors are equal then Bob will always
output equal in this protocol and the
second claim is that if Alice and Bob's
inputs are not equal they're not the
same vector then Bob will output not
equal with probability at least one
minus one over N where that probability
is over the random choice of the field
element R so essentially in both cases
they almost always output the right
answer in the first case they actually
always so the first claim should be
obvious if they're two input vectors are
equal then P and Q are just the same
polynomial so they agree at every point
in particular whatever point Alice picks
compare them at they're going to agree
at that point
so the interesting case is one 8 is not
equal B let's quickly run through the
the proof of this claim for this case so
the key fact that guarantees low
probability of outputting the wrong
answer in this case is the following if
P and Q are univariate polynomials of
degree at most n then P and Q can agree
on at most n inputs so this is just the
basic fact about low degree polynomials
it's actually equivalent to the
statement that any degree in polynomial
has at most n roots so a reformulation
of this statement is that the
probability over the random choice of r
that Alice picks that p and Q agree at
that input if they're not actually the
same polynomial is at most n over the
field size so we chose the field size to
be N squared just to ensure that this
failure probability is in most 1 over n
which was the field size to be even
bigger than N squared the failure
probability goes even smaller
any questions about that
so this had nothing to do with
interactive cruise there was no proof or
Alice and Bob trusted each other but
there were some interesting technical
takeaways from this protocol so the
first technical takeaway is that any too
low degree polynomials which are not the
same polynomial disagree at almost all
inputs that was this fact that we saw on
the previous slide and there's an
important corollary of this which is
that if in an interactive proof if a
verifier were to evaluate two
polynomials at the same point randomly
chosen points that only the verifier you
know chose herself and the two
polynomials agreed at that randomly
chosen point then it's somehow safe for
the verifier to believe they're actually
the same polynomial for that check to
pass and for them not to be the same
polynomial the verifier would had to get
very unlucky and pick one of the very
small number of points at which the two
polynomials did agree what do you mean
by low degree here yeah so in general
the probability that two distinct degree
n polynomials agree at a randomly chosen
input is that most their degree over the
field size so we just want this
probability to be small so for that for
it to be smaller the degree has to be
significantly smaller than the field
size that's all I mean
no questions
just for this example if they were to
take a run to point random index and
just some and send the Sun and then the
simplicity what do you mean a random
index and some I could get under Windex
and I sum all the beats between 0 and
yeah so for this example I don't think
so imagine that the two vectors disagree
in just one point you for that solution
to work I suppose you'd have to make
sure that that point is in the in debt
is in the range we're talking about and
maybe in that range the acids actually
disagree in two points and they cancel
out so that that solution would requires
more care so this is a worst-case
analysis no reason no malice intention
to try to look like women then the
chances that they even agree on the N
minus 1 other influences it's pretty
small it's the worst case right sure
yeah I mean if there if if you were like
promise that there two inputs disagree
add like a constant fraction of their
locations they could just like check a
randomly chosen location or something
but yeah so this is the worst case
analysis of course we're that's what
we'll be interested in interactive
proofs are a malicious setting so we
really want more space guarantees people
do it's not a topic for this talk anyway
how do you know added just a little
so in this part of the talk we're Hollis
and Bob are both trusted okay so they're
just going to follow the protocol we'd
tell them to follow so we're just
telling Alice look interpret your n bits
as the coefficients of a degree n
polynomial in alice is going to do it
for us
so the other takeaway from this protocol
is that interpreting inputs as low
degree polynomials is powerful so what's
happening in this in this equality
protocol is that if Alice and Bob's
inputs differ at even a single element
and once we interpret them as
polynomials those polynomials differ I
had almost all inputs that almost
everywhere and that's a powerful thing
somehow interpreting things as
polynomials and we slow degree
polynomials is like a difference
amplifying operation so that's the
reason I started with something that
wasn't an interactive proof to display
these two takeaways very cleanly
although it seems like it might have
caused a little bit of confusion but we
can now go back to proofs okay so the
next demonstration we'll see for the
power of randomness will be in the
context of verifiable computing interact
the proofs except it won't be
interactive so I'm going to give you a
non interactive protocol for the problem
of verifying matrix products so in this
problem the input is just two N by n
matrices whose entries are from a finite
field and the goal is to compute the
product matrix so the fastest known
algorithm for this problem runs in time
about n to the two point three seven and
that's not a practical algorithm and
it's a major research question can you
do any better but we're not interested
in solving this problem from scratch in
this talk because we're now interested
in proof systems so the question I want
to ask is what if an untrusted proved er
claims that you know he or she has
computed the correct answer so the
prover says here's the answer it's this
matrix C so the question is can that
answer be verified in time linear in the
input size so linear in the input size
will be faster than any known algorithm
that just solves the problem and the
answer is yes and that's what I want to
tell you about now does the problem make
sense
okay so here's the protocol so the
verifier will pick a random field
elements and it's going to let X be the
vector consisting of just all of the
powers from 1 to n of that field element
our R squared R cubed up to R to the N
and what the verifier is going to do is
it's going to multiply the claimed
answer by the vector X and also compute
the true answer times the vector X and
I'll explain in a moment how it can do
that quickly and it's going to accept if
and only if these they agree so there
should be reminiscent of the Equality
protocol that we talked about previously
in the Equality protocol like Alice and
Bob evaluated like they're two vectors
at a random input once you interpreted
them as polynomials and we're doing
something similar here by multiplying
the two matrices the claimed answer and
the real answer by kind of a randomly
chosen the vector would be the
difference the complexity bound that you
get by so if if it's a random 0 1 vector
I'll have to think offline about if that
works but I get so so that that might
yeah that might be fine let me so so so
this protocol is essentially due to free
balls from the late 70s although in free
vod's protocol the vector X was totally
random field elements every entry was an
independent random field element and for
my purposes I for specific reasons I
wanted to choose this more structured
vector X just this variant of free BOTS
protocol is actually due to kimberlyn
sin hi
so what you're describing probably works
as well but let's stick with this
variant any other questions about the
protocol itself so it's a two line
protocol
all right so let's talk about the
runtime so in this protocol the
verifiers runtime is dominated by just
computing 3 matrix vector products so
let me explain so the verifier has to
multiply C by X and the prover just is
handing the verifier C okay so that's
just one matrix vector multiplication
right the verifier see you see
explicitly so the tricky aspect is that
the verifier also hat also has to
compute a B times X but the whole point
of the problem is the verifier doesn't
know a times B that's what the verifier
would like to compute but thankfully
because of associativity of matrix
multiplication a B times X is the same
as a times B X so the verifier can
compute a B times X just by computing B
X with one matrix vector multiplication
and then multiplying that by a that's a
second matrix vector multiplication
matrix vector multiplication can be done
in time N squared is obviously an N
squared time operation these are n by n
matrices so N squared is linear in the
input size like multiplication can be
done units cost yes so throughout this
talk thank you for asking me to clarify
that I'm going to call addition to
multiplication in a field just one one
time step just for use of the county
and the best-known verification
algorithm ban is N squared log N or
sorry if knit this you if you use a
spits it's Travis bit I'd have to check
that offline but the only it's good the
elements of the field don't have like oh
maybe do they have like in terms of n
because well so I define the problem so
that the input matrix consists of
arbitrary field elements so you do have
to do general field multiplications but
for this talk we're just gonna call you
every field operation
okay so yeah so if we're calling field
operations one time step this is a N
squared time verifier and then you can't
do better than that
and this without accounting because the
verifier has to at least read the input
okay so why is this protocol correct
so it's correctness is captured by the
following two claims which is totally
analogous to the case of the
communication complexity of equality so
that is if the if the prover actually
sends the the true answer so C equals a
times B then the verifier will always
accept and if the prover sends the wrong
answer then the verifier will reject the
probability at least one minus one over
n all right so the first claim is is
obvious if you if C equals a times B
then when you multiply them both by X
you'll get out the same thing fire will
always the interesting case again is
claimed to so to prove this claim
recall that the vector X that the
verifier you know multiply C by and a
times B by is just all powers of are up
to n and this means that the the ithe
entry of C times X is is just this so
this is like the the dot product of the
I throw a C with the vector X and that's
identical to the reed-solomon
fingerprint at R of that row of C
so this is why I started with the
equality protocol before moving to this
so that I could just invoke the analysis
of the Equality protocol so similarly
the I entry of a B times X is the
reed-solomon fingerprint of the I throw
of a B so what this means is that if if
C is not exactly equal to a times B so
if they differ at even a single entry
then the row that that entry is in what
will be comparing the verifier will be
comparing the reed-solomon fingerprint
of you know that that row from the
claimed answer which does not equal that
row of the true answer and we've already
analyzed what happens in that case so we
said if you take the reed solomon
fingerprint of two vectors that are not
the same vector they will disagree with
probability at least one minus one Clark
today I'll have you completely par to
the N and so r times r times r
another game if we if you take my word
that is blue moderate in every
probabilistic covered with glass if you
think the effect of 0-1 and now you you
take the multiplication complexity
you'll get the same the same result by
repeating it repeating it Logan type
correct so yeah I'm not making any
special claims that there are benefits
of this over other variants
this is using concepts that will be
useful later in the talk
so there are other variants of this more
than one that will achieve the same cost
and so forth but this is a particularly
I wanted to do it but you don't know any
way of doing it to the N square actually
yeah I just haven't thought about it so
I think this is a great thing to think
about
I'll fly okay so those were that was our
detour you know away from interactive
proofs but to reveal the power of
randomness and by the way this III end
at 10
and it's not okay all right I'm doing
good all right okay okay so now we're
going to talk only about interactive
proofs for like the rest of the 90
minutes left or whatever I had so I need
to start with some preliminaries
introducing some important technical
notions so first I'm going to start with
something called the short zipper lemma
so this is a variant of the fact we've
previously seen in this talk which is
that if P and Q are two univariate
polynomials of degree at most D then the
probability they agree at a randomly
chosen input is at most D over the field
size so the short zippo lemma is an
extension of this to multivariate
polynomials it says that if P and Q are
distinct L vary polynomials of total
degree at most D and I'll clarify what
total degree means in a second then the
same kind of statement holds if you
evaluate them at randomly chosen input
they agree with probability and those do
over the field size just generalizing
from univariate to L vary upon what I
mean by total degree is just take every
term in the polynomial and take the one
where if you add up all the powers in
the term it's maximized so the total
degree of this polynomial is three
because this term has the sum of the
powers is three and dominates the total
degree of this term which is just two
so throughout this talk we'll actually
only need the univariate version but I
think it's still useful to know about
the short supply lemma and I believe
prologues going to use it in this
afternoon so a short simple lemma
motivates the the next notion we're
going to need which are called extension
polynomials so here's the definition so
suppose we are given a function f which
maps L bits to a field so an L variant
polynomial G over the field is said to
extend F if F and G agree that all of
the inputs where F is defined so f is
only defined here over 0 1 to the L but
G is defined over like field to the L
and G is said to extend F if F and G do
agree wherever F is defined so G is like
somehow extending the domain of F to a
much bigger set from 0 1 to the L tap to
the
does that make sense
so any function mapping zero one to the
l2f has a unique extension which is
multi linear multi linear means that the
polynomial has degree at most one in
each variable okay so for example this
is a multi linear polynomial because the
degree is at most one in each variable
and this is not because this term has
degree 2 and next one this is a real
okay so so so so f is defined over L
variables L is fixed F is just like a
fixed function so for any function
defined over domain 0 1 to the L there's
a unique multi linear polynomial that
extends F
this is a really important technical
notion so please ask more questions you
already have original smaller well I'm
so actually mixed slide has a picture so
maybe let's let's see the picture and
then ask your question again if you take
multilinear any and you know what is
that always exists a unique 0 1 between
vectors that will give you the F tilde
fluid correct it's one-to-one
correspondence yes but we only need the
one direction of that correspondence in
going from functions defined only on 0 1
on to the L to the multi-layered
extensions
ok so here's here's the picture you
should have in mind for extension so
here's a function f defined on 0 1 2 you
know two-dimensional 0 1 and here is its
multi linear extension so the multiliner
extension is there's there's a row for
every field element and a column for
every field element so I you know I
don't have an infinitely big sliding I
cut it off so you can see the the multi
linear extension right it agrees with
the original function on the top left
corner that is the boolean hypercube
but the multi linear extension has a
much bigger domain and there are other
extensions of F as well so here's
another extension of F so this is not
multilinear because it has a quadratic
term but nonetheless it agrees with F
everywhere F is defined in this top left
corner
so I think the way you should think
about these low degree extensions is the
following they're like different
amplifying and codings of of F right and
the cents short Zippo tells us that if
two functions defined on the boolean
hypercube disagree and even a single
location then their low degree
extensions have to disagree almost
everywhere right because their low
degree extensions can't be the same
since they disagree other and an input
polynomials disagree
other questions about the extensions
again cuz the original yes mm-hmm
the only thing the constraint is that
you know it's any mapping you've done
the subdomain on 0 1 2 Miguel it's still
expressly there was a such a thing
airing every yeah yeah I mean so that
fact is polynomial interpolation I guess
like you can take any function you can
fit a polynomial to it and that's all
that these are doing right so because
the interpolating set here is just it's
very structured is 0 1 to the L that
ensures that you can always fit a multi
linear polynomial to it and right but
there were various reasons why we will
not always want to use multi linear
extensions but it's nice to know that
you can fit them up
sorry I think the question I have is
because I think the point is that your
degree one this gives you like to to the
end degrees of freedom so the point here
is that you're kind of fit to the end
points not that getting necessarily
lined up in this too
I claim somebody and this is probably
true just replace this as some other
point right so so it's definitely the so
I'm not sure I don't know if algebra to
answer this precisely I think the
structure of the interpolating set does
matter but all we're gonna need for this
talk is that if you're interpolating set
is 0 1 to the L then there always is a
multilinear so what is the domain of G
is it have to be all or that to the AL
yes so this picture giving an evaluation
of the extension I move to the G 1 for
every input to G there's a there
supposed to be a row for every field
element and a column for every feelin
because that's FF to the main of G is on
the field to the L
more questions
all right great so when we actually use
these low degree extensions and
interactive proves the verifier
naturally will sometimes have to
evaluate the low degree extensions at an
input so it's important that that can be
done quickly so I just want to mention
one result which is suppose we're given
all 2 to the L evaluations of F which is
defined on 0 under the L as input and
there's an algorithm that can take also
as input in addition to the evaluations
a random vector in FL and in order 2 to
the L time okay and that's a linear time
if the input is actually specifying an
evaluation for every every video 2 to
the L time for evaluating the multi
linear extension at that end throughout
the whole talk our thematic operations
over the field addition or
multiplication is one
that's open that I just don't I haven't
thought about it I I always counted
operation so in operation I don't think
about big complexity
so let me just say that again so if I
gave you all two to the elevations of
some function f as an input and you
wanted to evaluate them all to in their
extension of f at a random input you
could do it in time order 2 to the L
now in the solution or bids oh yeah so
so using the garage interpolation you
would get an extra log factor here so
the runtime would be 2 to the L times L
and vu it all have a nice dynamic
programming trick to save that log
factor but if you just did a grant
interpolation just seemed to fit small
it doesn't matter this might save you
time even in the bit model because in
the bit more you might have to log
factors going to 1 ok so so in some
context this order 2 to the L time like
won't be nice for us so I did want to
mention and we'll see an example of this
shortly that if the function f has some
nice structure to it then sometimes
there's a low degree extension might not
be multilinear that can be evaluated
much faster than 2 to the L time
this slide might make more sense when we
actually see the interactive proofs and
realize hey the verifier needs to
evaluate this polynomial quickly and I
tell you
all right so we got through all of the
dry technical preliminaries and finally
I can talk about what I consider a real
highlight the some check protocol which
is due to lund fort now Karloff and
Nissan and I want to stress it in my
view this is this is really the one
hammer you need to know if you want to
design an efficient interactive proof so
if you're ever find yourself in need of
an efficient interactive proof for some
problem the very first thing you should
do is make sure you understand the
subject protocol and just try to apply
it and now if I fall I convey in the
next in the remaining however much time
I have left is is that fact then I'll be
satisfied
okay so let's dive into the protocol so
on his face if you've never seen it
before it probably looks like it's
solving some esoteric problem that can't
possibly be very useful but it turns out
to be so we're going to think of the
input as follows to just to present the
subject protocol on its own so think of
the verifier in this protocol has given
oracle access to an L very polynomial G
so what this means is the verifier can
go to the oracle and say hey oracle tell
me the evaluation of g add this input
and the oracle just comes back and says
here's the evaluation the evaluation of
g a template so in real applications
there won't be any oracle that's some
like idealized setting that doesn't
correspond to the real world but to
present the protocol itself it's nice to
think of the verifier as having this
oracle as the so that's all the verifier
can do really is is go to the oracle and
say give me a G's value at this input
and what the verify I want to do is it
wants to some G's values at all to to
the L boolean inputs
that's the problem our gonna solve again
I'm not sure like I wouldn't look at
this having for the first time in think
oh that's obviously a useful thing to do
but it turns out to be useful so that's
what we're going to do okay so it turns
out the subject protocol can fit on
really half a slide I'll take the whole
slide so here's how it works at the
start the prover just sends the claimed
answer all right so this the the
verifier now needs to check does this
claim to answer c1 actually equal the
true answer which is this big song sure
okay so given that the so L is how can
the verifier solve this problem herself
and all the verifier can do is actually
ask the Oracle to to the L questions it
can go to the Oracle and say hey give me
the value of G at input zero zero zero
zero there's a zero one and just walk
through every term of this giant sum and
compute the answer herself that
obviously takes 2 to the L Oracle
queries and in particular at least to
the other and we're going to have the
verifier running much faster time than
that
okay so at the start of the protocol the
provers just sent the claimed answer and
nothing else so the verifier needs to
now check is this claimed answer correct
so in the first round of the protocol
the prover sends a univariate polynomial
which I'll call s1 which is claimed to
equal this thing okay so what is this
thing so this this thing has just taken
the true answer this big sum and it's
lopped off the first sum the sum over b1
sum this sum over the first variable and
it's just left the first variable free
does everyone see that
and the answer is you know summing G
over all 2 to the L boolean inputs and
this thing is doing something very
similar except it's leaving the first
variable free and not summing over it at
all now the size of s1 or this just
let's not worry about so so so s okay
right so s1 itself is a univariate
polynomial well sorry this thing which
the which s1 is supposed to equal
there's a univariate polynomial how what
is its degree well it's at its degree is
that most the degree of G and variable
one because each one of these terms with
the bees fixed is just polynomial of
degree at most
so like in applications you know G might
have degree three in each variable or
something the point is whatever the
degree of G is in each variable is going
to be it's going to be low low degree so
s1 is just a low degree unity really
other questions
so let me give this thing a name this is
what s1 is supposed to be I'm gonna call
it h1 and h1 is precisely defines so
that the true answer equals H 1 of 0
plus h 1 o 1 does everyone see that so
if you if you plug in 0 for X 1 what you
get out of this sum is exactly all of
the terms for the true answer as where B
1 is fixed to 0 and if you plug in 1 for
X 1 you get all the terms of the
somewhere B 1 is just 1 so this this
thing H 1 is like precisely defined so
the true answer is H 1 a 0 plus h 1
okay so the verifier just checks that
that holds for the claim dancer that is
does the claim dancer equal s 1 of 0
plus s 101 all right so this check is
like designed to pass so long as s 1
actually equals H 1 so at this point in
the protocol it's actually safe for the
verifier to believe that the clam dancer
is correct so long as the verifier
actually believes that s 1 and H 1 are
the same polynomial I mean because if if
that's one actually equals H 1 then I
just said like the claim dancer equals
the true answer because the translation
so how can the verifier convince herself
that s1 and h1 are the same polynomial
well this harks back to reed-solomon
fingerprinting you can just evaluate the
two polynomials at a random point if
they agree at that point so long as the
verifier chose that point at random then
it's safe to believe in the same color
so the entire rest of the protocol is
just devoted to checking that s1 and h1
agree at this random point that's what
these um that's what these two bullets
say so V picks this random point r1 and
the rest of the protocol is devoted to
checking that s1 and h1 degree at that
point okay now the problem with just you
know verifier can't just check this
directly because the verifier doesn't
know what h 1 is h 1 is defined by this
big sum which is almost as big as the
you know original sum defining the
original problem the verifier can't just
compute H 1 of R 1 but fortunately H 1
of R 1 has a nice form so this right
hand side here is H 1 of R 1 and this is
exactly the kind of sum that the sum
check protocol can compute and moreover
we've made some nice progress because
now the polynomial we're summing over
its it has one fewer variable so the
polynomial or something over now is G
but with the first variable fixed to our
one polynomial now has L minus 1
variables instead available
okay so that's the subject protocol in
half a slide so the the provers cents s1
which was claimed to equal this thing
the verifier checked that this equality
held the verifier picked a random point
r1 sent it to the prover and then they
just rehearsed to verify that this
equality holds it can just keep do keep
doing this keep recursing eventually you
have to stop her cursing and there's a
natural point to stop recursing and
that's in the final round round round el
the the thing that you would normally
recurse on is to check that SLE of RL
equals g with all L of the variables
bound so like each round of this
protocol is binding another variable to
another random value and eventually all
L of the variables get bound and then at
that point there's no need to recurse
because the verifier can compute G at
with all variables down just with one
Oracle query
there's a protocol make sense
so that's the protocol and I hope I
presented in a way that kind of
motivates why it works the way it does
you know kind of as I was presenting it
but now we'll just analyze it so even if
you thought it was unmotivated you'll
see that it works whether whether it's
motivated or not okay so let's start by
talking about completeness and soundness
so completeness holds by design so like
the the only checks that the verifier
did in the whole protocol were checks of
this form you know does some claim value
equal a message evaluated at 0 plus
evaluated at 1 and I kind of explains
you know as I was describing the
protocol that those checks were designed
specifically to pass if the provers on
is the claimed answer is in fact H 1 is
0 plus h 101 so if the verifier actually
sends h 1 and round 1 the check will
pass so that's so completeness holds
with probability 1 and honest
so the interesting direction is
soundness which says if the prover
doesn't send all the prescribed messages
where at least let me put it this way if
the prover doesn't send the true answer
at the start of the protocol then the
verifier rejects with high probability
so the soundness error grows linearly
with the degree of the polynomial G that
you're summing over so I'm actually
going to run through the whole soundness
proof slide in half and you can prove
this by induction on the number of
variables L and that shouldn't be too
surprising because each round of the
subject protocol we were kind of binding
another variable to a random value and
thereby reducing the number of variables
that later rounds had to sum over so it
kind of makes sense that you would
analyze the protocol kind of variable to
have variable so we're doing induction
over the number of variables here so the
base case is l equals 1 and in this case
the protocol is so simple as to be
almost a triviality if you're trying to
sum up a one very polynomial and you
what all the prover does in the in the
protocol is send a single message s1
which is claimed to equal the input
polynomial itself so if you specialize
this sum check protocol to the case
where there's one variable there's only
one message from the prover and that
message is supposed to just be the input
polynomial and all the verifier does in
that case is pick a random input and
make sure with one Oracle query to the
true input Paulino moji that the message
and the input agree at that point we've
already seen if s1 and g we're not the
same polynomial then if you evaluate
them both at around the point you would
do something different
so in the in the base case for the
soundness analysis it really just boils
down to this facts that any
so the inductive case works as follows
so now we're considering a general
number L of variable as where L is
greater than 1 and recall that the
previous first message s 1 is supposed
to equal this polynomial H 1 and the way
that the verifier in the protocol
checked that s 1 and H 1 actually were
equal was to pick a random R 1 and kind
of recursively check that s 1 of R 1
equals H 1 of R 1 all right and again we
can exploit this fact that if s 1 does
not equal H 1 then with high probability
over the choice of R 1 they're going to
disagree in here is that they agree with
low probability and the point is if they
do disagree then the prover has left to
prove a cross claim in the recursive
call so that's the key insight here that
kind of reduces the general case to your
inductive hypothesis because the
recursive call is applying the sum check
probably normal to an L minus 1 very
polynomial so we know by induction that
the prove are fails to convince the
verifier in the recursive call of a
false claim just by the inductive
hypothesis except with very small
probability
so if you actually put all this together
what you conclude is that if the if the
first message s1 does not equal what
it's supposed to equal then the
probability of the verifier accepts is
that most bounded by one of two things
so either the the prover gets lucky in
the first round and the verifier picks
an r1 at which s1 and and what it's
supposed to equal agree even though they
don't or the or the prover gets lucky in
some later round and and he this we
bounded directly by our key fact that
we've used over and over again this
clock and this we bounded just by the
inductive hypothesis
their benefits in doing it move around
very quickly just send over all dris so
there is no known as it's almost
certainly impossible to do this without
interaction unless things we totally
believe are definitely false I turned
out to be true
oh you still have interaction is that
you much less have like constant visitor
so the proposal was to send you just
send all of them oh I see so just one
round of interaction yeah this it was so
what a it would not work what that
proposal it's very important in this
analysis that when the prove ourselves
any polynomial in any round it has no
idea what the next ROI is gonna be
so I'm gonna see what is the
significance of having exactly two
points in its dimension and the points
we zero in one this seems completely
arbitrary I couldn't work that's right
that's right
yeah so I introduced you know the input
domain being zero one because that's
what we'll need in applications and it
keeps things country but no you can you
can do the sum over any set any any like
product set so there's not important
that zero one of the yellow could be any
in particular if I did that you know so
in each dimension once will you have a
degree so if I found or took any I could
really compute any point yeah yeah I
think everything you're saying
nowhere in the subject protocol was it
important that you know this set was
zero zero one to the L all that all that
mattered was that G had low degree in
each variable but we'll see you know and
all the applications for this talk like
zero one to the yellows that domain you
care about it so this'll make more sense
just makes things more but you need to
dis more because otherwise you're
something yep it's a zero plus x1 all
right so where do you need to be small
yeah yeah sure yeah I mean ultimately um
yeah that's right but it could have been
also with this one at that point you
could think you could you could collapse
rounds out of the protocol if if you're
there's a variable you're not summing
over but as an optimization but yeah
let's just say the thing I can say
concretely and for sure is that you can
take any any product set and as long as
the product set is kind of small in each
dimension the Assumption protocol will
work in the efficient
is there any essential difference
between this well they took me some 35
years ago I'd be equally spaced now this
will get you almost all the way type
equals piece based on its own in this
what's coming next so this is the
subject protocol is like really the
hammer that you want to do anything
within around
so what's the attack if you send all the
ours so like imagine at round one that
before the prover sends s1 it actually
knew what r1 would be then he could send
an s-1 that's not equal to what it
should be it's a different polynomial
but they just agree at r1 this is where
unpredictability of the verifiers
messages is essential why the messages
need to be randomized
so I think we're almost done with the
subject protocol we now understand it's
complete and sound I'm just going to
summarize its costs and then I think
it's time for the break right so if G
had degree at most D in each variable
then in each round of the protocol and
there were L rounds the prover was
sending a degree D univariate polynomial
so the total communication is order D
times L field elements and moreover when
the verifier processes each message like
all I was doing it's the verifier would
take each message which is a degree d
polynomial and it would evaluate at 0
and 1 and sum the two you know and
compare that to the preceding to some
value from the preceding round so what
this means is the verifier can process
each message it's very simple check it's
processing each message and when you're
time and the size of the message so the
verifier is runtime over all L rounds is
just order D times L it's just
processing each message in linear time
in the size of message and at the very
end of the protocol the verifier has to
you know ask the Oracle for the
evaluation of G at one randomly chosen
form as everything the very part is
the prover runtime I don't want to get
into it in great detail but so I'm just
gonna assert and hope you believe me
that the runtime of the prover is is
pretty close to just the time required
to solve the problem in the first place
so to just solve the problem with no
proof of correctness
the problem was summing G at 2 to the L
inputs so if the prover only has Oracle
access to G it can only be done in time
to the L times it turns out you can
actually implement the prover in the
some check protocol in just a factor D
slower than
so feel free to ask questions but I
think that's what I wanted to get
through before the break
five minutes if you wanna ask questions
or break
so am i right to claim the the only
client the fact that Jesus used is in
the sentence I think that's right I mean
of course the protocol is defined so
that everything being transmitted from
the approver to the verifier use a
polynomial but that's that's yeah but
you're right I mean that's the key
that's what everything boils down to is
low degree polynomials because of this
key fact that any to low degree
polynomials that are not the same
disagree at almost all inputs that is
key to the soundness analysis that's
what's giving the verifier all of this
power over the prover to make sure the
prover has to send exactly the right
message in every round or else the
protocol so right so here's the book
because I have some probability that two
random functions with slightly different
patters will this matches actually I'd
like to take item functions so which
doesn't work there is once we do this
conditioning the resulting thing cannot
be sent over and like in the fewer
number of bits
any other questions
okay so I got through like the key
hammer that is unlocks all powerful
interactive proofs
so we'll actually start applying this
hammer
[Applause]